yes uh Michael Cahill from Newmarket I
represent Rockingham 10 the towns of
Newmarket and new Fields this is my
sixth term on labor which I'll say once
more that this is the best committee
having served on none other I'm still
sure this is the best committee because
we do you know we do the bills we don't
do the partisan stuff we do the work and
uh I like Drummond I'm a bass player but
I'm Mike Drago I represent Raymond this
is my first time on the labor committee
actually first time at the State Rep so
I'm learning a lot I'm taking Michael's
advice saying that this is the best
hi I'm Don Bouchard and I represent
Manchester's Ward 4 and this is my third
term sitting on labor
uh and I'm a retired physical science
teacher
and it is the best committee
hello I'm Lindy D Silvestro Manchester
this is my sixth term in labor had will
a couple of times as our chair very good
uh my business is real estate and I
concur that this is the best committee
right good morning Mr chairman uh my
name is Mark McKenzie I am a second I'm
returning uh to the house so my second
term I had a bit of a Hiatus uh I have a
long relationship with the labor
committee that goes back many many years
as I was the president of the AFL-CIO
and Lobby here and sat many many many
hours over the course of the years in
this committee so it's it's fun to be on
this side uh I live in Manchester
represent the float the district 40 uh
in this in the city of Manchester
howdy sorry
trying to get a medical appointment in
um Brian Sullivan I represent Sullivan
district one which is my hometown of
Grantham
um I've been uh
on the labor committee since 2018 I
guess uh and um
I I did and I was pretty green at the
hi I'm Chris Schultz we're sitting in my
District Welcome to my um District I
represent a floaterial that represents
about third of a third of Concord
um I have worked for labor unions
including the international AFL-CIO in
DC and I should have been on this
committee when I first was elected three
terms ago
um but here I am now better late than
never
thank you uh Brian seaworth I'm from
Pembroke and Pembroke is the whole of my
district now
um I have been on this committee since
it was my last choice in my first year
2011 and I have never left
um I've been on I've been the clerk of
this committee twice and now this is my
second term as the vice chairman so
looking forward to that
uh by education I'm a mechanical
engineer I've worked in uh the electric
industry I've worked in Rockets very
briefly electric Rockets
so just a little background thank you
I'm also rocket scientist I actually my
my business card said engineer scientist
back when I was designing Rockets So
representative attitude
thank you Mr chairman uh Josh hatchton
uh representing Grafton 16 Enfield
um second term on House labor and just
foreign
hey how's it going uh Michael Granger
here uh worked on a farm when I was a
kid uh did a little bit of factory work
and now I'm working in computers in
salary which is uh which is a change of
pace but I'm representing Stratford
District 2 which includes Rochester Ward
I want to thank you Mr chairman Tim
soucy from Concord serving my fourth
term in Concord third on the labor
committee
um Vice chair with Brian as a on our
first term retired firefighter from
Nashua 29 years and I'm happy to be back
thank you Mr chair Dan Leclair uh one of
the three reps of Amherst my freshman
term uh 27-year member of the Carpenters
Union five years as a business agent in
New Hampshire and looking very forward
to working with all of you
and look
good morning everybody Dave love from
Derry
um I I did a half a term on uh on
fishing game last year when we finished
up uh they uh they put me over here and
uh back for my second term
Mr chairman uh I'm rashay kolkum from
Hillsboro I represent Hillsboro antrum
Bennington and Windsor I uh spent 25
years in management in the commercial
HVAC industry I am retired and now a
professional volunteer so this is just
added to my list of volunteers so I'm a
my name is Steve Boyd I represent
district 10 Dunbarton and Hooksett this
is my second term on labor a retired
test engineer
lots of free time to
bill
um uh I actually grew up in Amherst I
don't know if you're aware of that
representative
um and then moved to Manchester and
decided I wanted to be a state
representative one day and this is my
eighth ninth term I believe and I um
spent my first term uh with Ray Buckley
uh teaching me how things should go on
the election law committee
and uh then um
I got chosen to be the vice chairman of
this committee and Rusty Bridal if any
of you remember Rusty was a firefighter
from Hampton
and um he informed me a week into the
legislature that he was having a hip
operation he was going to be gone for
six weeks
so I got thrown into trying to trying to
act as his chair and that's how I
learned everything it was shotgun
I'm happy to be back
um
I'm as you know many of you know me I'm
a little more informal
um in this room when you're on camera we
got to call each other Representatives I
don't care what you call each other my
name's will if you see me in the Hall of
me I'm not chairman I'm not this I'm
just will and that's the way I like it
um so you can call me whatever you want
but I just prefer that
um we try to run the committee so we
um in a non-combative way
we get into some issues at times that we
know that are very emotional for either
side
and at times we will disagree and we
have
um we try not to be disagreeable in the
room
um and I again I understand it can be uh
angering
um if you really want something and it
it may fail or you don't want something
and it passes
um
ultimately we're all trying to do a good
job of the best of our abilities so I
like to give people leeway
um when asking a question if it's a
run-on question or it's really not one
of those questions that some of you
freshmen will learn when you kind of
make a statement and it's not really a
question
um you know we all try to help everybody
out with that I think the only thing
that really bothered me that that I
really don't like
um to be careful of
is
how sometimes we treat
some of the people that come up in front
of us and and will speak on behalf or
against a bill
we could be really gung-ho in favor of
what they're saying or really adamantly
against what they're saying
and
um you know we kind of got to keep our
emotions the way they are and if you
want to ask a question that's fine they
re the the goal of asking a question is
to learn something
not to say well are you aware that
everything you're saying is is in
violation of of so and so or con totally
contradictive to these three articles
that's not really
um
you're arguing your point we don't argue
our point with the presenter it's okay
to challenge something they say and ask
them to
be a little more specific or clarify
what they're saying
um but just try to be respectful and and
again
um
it's going to take a lot for me to gavel
you to stop
I like to try to let everyone
um
you know Act is the way they feel they
should as a representative so just just
a couple of those things to keep in mind
um we're going to have a much more
difficult
schedule than we've ever had that I can
recall
not the number of bills we have which
are 14 so much but we have nine early
bills those are bills with a financial
note next to them
um as as many you know when you have a
bill we are the policy committee we're
going to decide on the policy but if it
has some kind of mechanism that may cost
the state or County money it has to go
to a division of the finance
to determine whether or not they want to
pass it there the the money committee
after we go through ours
because of that we have to have nine of
these bills out of here by February 16th
um which is three quarters of of the
amount of bills we have
now
um
this room is occupied by two other
committees
and Labor's always had Thursday and I
got a great call from representative
colcum saying well how do we meet on
Thursdays if we're going to have house
sessions on Thursdays
normally there was plenty of time in
between
and it's never been a problem this year
it's going to be a problem
number one we're going to have so many
bills that come out that have no
recommendation that there's going to be
a lot more debate on the floor
so they're trying to schedule more house
sessions thinking it's going to take a
lot longer than it has in the past
um
so they're holding these and then we
have to have so many out so early so a
combination of these things the schedule
so far is going to be the if you've seen
the maybe you haven't seen the calendar
we're going to be hearing six bills on
the 19th
it'll be in the calendar tomorrow and
then
five on the 26th
Thursday the 19th Thursday the 26th I've
been told by the the clerk that will not
be house sessions on those two days so
we can do that
we do have long days here but I
recognize people have jobs and other
things that they can't be here and I
want to do two a day and three a day and
have you come back two days a week we
try to do a full day so we start at 10
A.M
cognitive the fact that some people have
to drive here a distance so we're
starting at 10 A.M and our last hearing
is usually around three o'clock which
gives us time to be out of here
hopefully by four o'clock or if we're
behind if any uh because I have to make
a guess when I look at every bill and I
read every bill I have to make a guess
and how many minutes it's going to take
um and do I need an hour do I need a
half an hour or what have you to to go
through that hearing so we have a little
fudge room at the end or before lunch I
try to make it so we can get caught up
I will not be here the 19th so Brian is
going to take the chair and take care of
the the bills on the 19th if anyone
wants to write them down right now
because they're interested I will breed
them off if anyone would like to know
what bills we're going to be hearing on
the 19th
oh she already has it out excellent okay
so you know
um and you can see um all five of all
six of those bills
um and they all have to be out early
some of these we've seen before some are
interested be interesting I will be
watching I believe when we're on Zoom
I'll be watching uh but I just won't be
here in the 20s on the 19th I am aware
people have already told me I can't be
here on the 26th Camp here in the 19th I
understand that
but we have to keep up with what you
know with with hearing these bills
and then get caught up with your your
fellow Representatives if you have any
questions about what went on and you can
see the videos because I believe they're
um after they're where our hearings are
recorded they're on YouTube
so you can catch
um what went on and the questions back
and forth
uh and then you see the ones we have in
the 26th three more FNS
and I was just you know given four more
bills I guess in the last 24 hours so
we'll be scheduling those
yeah
grab that one right there next to you
yeah that's it
doesn't
all right well
okay just if you want to go through this
list
on the uh
is an FN 57 is an FN 58 is an FN 74 82
[Music]
and 190.
and 232 on the back page
rfns
there is one bill on the 26 at one
o'clock
that is the OSHA Bill I'm going to call
it
you can hear the numbers of the Bills or
the
oh the OSHA Bill I'm going to call it
it's House Bill uh 232.
this was a study a bill that was a study
committee that uh representative
seaworth and I was Sullivan shared and
representative avalani who's not here
not me
I wasn't on okay that's correct I always
think you were sorry represent abalani
who's not here representative Sullivan
and I we worked on this this um update
to our current OSHA standards for
um
non-public employees
um put and the reason is it's very
complicated and it's a multi-hundred
page OSHA document and there's a few
things in there that we want to take out
um
and we also need to hear from
municipalities the the concept is to
take OSHA standards that the Private
Industry must use and bring it to some
of the public industry which does not
have them is not ruled by OSHA bring
some of that up to speed to Department
well it admits they've kind of
we're utilizing an old
um version of the rules it needed to be
sparked up
um and everyone's pretty much in
agreement but we want to hear from
people that may not be able to
be here at the hearing or possibly say
well we like this but we don't like this
because this is the problem it's going
to cause
one of the biggest mistakes we've all
probably made as legislators before in
our careers here have been making
passing a law that we thought was a good
idea and not really understanding
everything that was going to happen we
do our best
and then you find out the subsequent
Year oops that wasn't really good we got
to amend it now because that's not what
we meant Mike you representative kale
you have something uh that you're going
to bring up this year on um labor laws
uh that was a mistake that was not
thought of during the process last year
so
um that's the reason for the
subcommittee on this one
um
so I just I just wanted to know in
advance
um if that's the only one I anticipate
having a subcommittee on
today we're going to have the Department
of Labor excuse me Employment Securities
followed by labor those are the two
um
Departments of the state that
most of our laws
are adjudicated by
um so they're a great resource we work
well with them
um
they will always tell you uh they're
very cautious with their opinions
because their job is to enforce
the laws that are put in place
and so they they will answer our
questions they will give us
some opinions if we ask but they try to
stay on that line of not telling us what
they want or don't want
so it's it's a delicate Balancing Act uh
any of the veterans I think we've always
had a very good relationship uh with the
two departments uh what they had to what
the Employment Securities had to go
through covid and some of the other
things
um new computer systems all the things
we've dealt with over the years to try
to make them better
um and it's always been a good
relationship so they'll be uh
who's first
appointment security is at 10 30. and
then labor at 11 15. they'll put a
presentation on give you an idea of what
they do
and um
I don't have a problem necessarily if
you have an issue or a question with a
bill
that you contact them directly that is
your right as a representative to do
that
if there are a number of questions it
would be it's easier sometimes if it
goes through me and I present it out to
them and they present it back but I'm
not going to preclude anybody from you
know contacting these people if they
have a question
um
so
that being said Mr Vice chairman do you
have any comments
nothing bad okay do I have any questions
or comments or nasty jokes or not nasty
nasty comments
your mother's listening
do you have a question
just wanted to see if we could record
the two presentations
because I believe the other committees
have been doing that to make it
I don't think in the next eight minutes
I'm going to be able to record this
because I don't think we have any of the
I don't I don't know I will ask I will
um
I will after your question I'll take a
couple minutes before they start at 10
30 to see if that's a quick turn on a
simple thing I quite frankly didn't even
notice the camera up in the corner they
were so used to seeing them here I
didn't even notice that one
um are there any other
version of kale
I was watching some other committees and
they seem to be recording I don't know
well
see no more questions I will go find out
it might be because
foreign
we're gonna start again folks
I I want you to know that this is being
streamed
and recorded
and I was told that I was remiss on one
important item to discuss
when we have an executive session and
there's a motion made by an individual
representative
You by making that motion you're
responsible for writing the committee
report
what we all used to call blurbs which I
guess we're not supposed to call them
anymore the committee report
um
I really want you to write them while
you're here
we are going to have a very tight
schedule so write them out I can review
them approve them and we can get them
over to our clerk
um uh Heather I don't know if you folks
have known Heather goalie who has been
um our assistant for many many years is
retiring at the end of this month
I don't know who's replacing her
but she's a well-oiled machine and kept
all the paperwork
um
very well organized the last couple
years
and so I don't know what's going to
happen so please understand if if you're
writing either the majority report or
The Minority Report really needed to be
in here write it after we have the
executive session
um obviously if you you got to get some
details or a few other things and you
just can't
finish it I respect that and you have to
give it to me the next day or so but
that's that's um something I'd like to
try to get done this
this session
uh further Ado uh my pleasure to
introduce some good friends
commissioner copadas assistant
commissioner lovers from the employment
all right we brought plenty of reading
material over for you guys that can also
function as a mild sedative as I told
some of you
so
real quick what I think gives a nice
um
overview of what's going on at the
department what we're responsible for
and the types of bills that come before
this committee that we'll have
discussions about so the the materials
that we handed out one was just an
updated law and rule book that we
provide to the members at the beginning
of every session
also we provided a copy of our Workforce
training program manual so this is
information on each and every program
that the department provides both for
individuals and for employers so we use
this pamphlet when we're out talking to
business groups when we're out talking
to individuals about various ways we can
assist with getting them training
helping them connect with hiring
employers so it's a nice quick
description of each of the programs so
when something does come up a proposal
comes up to make a a change or do
something with it with a training
program you can you can see a
description of everything that the
department is involved in from a
training perspective or a quick
description of the unemployment comp
program as well and then we also
provided you with a with a copy of
what's labeled the quick tips book so
this is a book that individuals receive
when they shortly after filing an
initial claim for unemployment benefits
they come in to the department for an
in-person Workshop
it's a benefits rights orientation so
they come in we provide them with this
they sign off as having received it and
then staff in each of the employment
security local offices then do about an
hour hour-long Workshop reviewing
reviewing all the do's and don'ts of
filing for benefits so those are some
materials just to have so you can
reference them later on in the session
and then we also have some slides that
we thought we would go over today what
we did was we had
had a conversation yesterday with joint
Ways and Means and we pulled some of the
material that was relevant for this
group to be able to just talk about
today to give you a sense of where
things are currently within the world of
Employment Security in terms of what
we're involved so really focused on
labor force the unemployment program
unemployment insurance taxes and then
some re-employment programs and what
we're currently planning to do in 2023
so we can start with that and then any
questions that any of the members have a
commissioner capatus and I will do our
best to answer those but just ask those
along the way and stop us whenever you
need to
that sound good wonderful
okay so with the um
but the slides that we had distributed
out
this first one is just to give you an
update as to where the state's private
sector labor force currently is so this
is a a comparison of all states New
Hampshire being in the red line and what
it does is it provides a a comparison of
how each state has fared in terms of
private sector payroll jobs recovery so
this is information that's taken from
the monthly survey of employers so you
get two surveys each month that get that
get put out one is the household survey
that's how the unemployment rate is
calculated the other survey is the a
survey of employers and that's a survey
finding out you know how many jobs they
currently have and these are jobs in New
Hampshire so with the the household
survey the person surveyed could be
working in New Hampshire could be
working a master true suits or Maine or
Vermont but they live in New Hampshire
here with this survey these are jobs in
New Hampshire and what you see here is
New Hampshire's recovery
when we look at the jobs lost during the
pandemic caused recession New Hampshire
is now about 1.1 percent above where we
were prior to the pandemic at our Peak
so November 2019 was our pre-pandemic
Peak from a private sector employment
perspective we are now about 6 500 jobs
or 1.1 percent above where we were in
November of 19. you can see Maine is
right up there with us with a slightly
ahead in terms of a 1.4 percent gain
since their pre-pandemic Peak other New
England states are lagging up pretty far
behind
and moving on to the next slide
we certainly as you know from hearing
from constituents and businesses in your
District the recovery in terms of a jobs
recovery has not been equal across all
of our sectors right so overall private
sector employment up 1.1 percent or
about 6 500 jobs that's great news but
it's not necessarily equally shared
amongst all our sectors in this these
next slides try to give you a sense of
what sectors
are currently still experiencing a loss
compared to their employment level prior
to the pandemic and what sectors have
experienced again and we try to put that
into perspective as well yes Mr chairman
what is accommodation accommodation is
lodging so that would be our hotels
motels so it it is broken out from
um restaurants here
thank you
um so the the large the the gains and
and this data is taken from actual
employer reports so this is not survey
data this is taken from our qcew program
our quarterly census of
um and employment and wages so that is
information filed by New Hampshire
employers each quarter when they report
to us who's working for them and how
much they were paid and that's how their
their unemployment insurance taxes are
calculated so from those reports we were
able to draw this information Broken Out
by sector and you can see professional
scientific Technical Services sector big
gains big gains from an employment
perspective so these are
tend to be more higher paying jobs these
are jobs within Legal Services these are
a lot of I.T related occupations engine
engineering firms architectural firms
but Professional Services but big gain
compared to where they were prior to the
pandemic construction up pretty
significantly but as we move down this
slide into the sectors that continue to
be at a loss compared to where where
they were prior to the pandemic you see
a lot of our health care employers so
long-term care hospitals still with
significant losses social assistance
that's where our child care employers
would be captured would be in social
assistance significant losses
from an employment perspective number of
employees and state government state
government down close to 1500 employees
and that's just State that's not local
as well local is captured separately we
didn't have it on this slide
um and then retail retail down
significantly from where they were prior
to the pandemic
um when we look at the percentage what
those numbers really mean for those
sectors you can see in the next Slide
the percentage uh gain or loss to help
you understand how significant it is for
that particular sector so nursing and
residential care facilities are
long-term care facilities that's a eight
and a half percent drop in employment
and again this is data as reported by
those employers
state government just over seven percent
hospitals nearly six percent and Retail
employers down almost five and a half
percent
um
so it what I understand is that you
indicated in the the gain of 1.1 percent
that that did that equals 6 500 jobs is
that what you suggested correct so the
what I'm looking at now is uh the
percentage gains not the percentage
gains but the actual gains uh in the
other page
and the job there's a lot more jobs that
I'm seeing
so is that a is that an Apples to Apples
comparison so you've got for instance in
the professional science Services you've
so jobs created and and the the the data
from these two slides so when you the
slide that you referenced before that
first one showing that 1.1 percent
increase that's taken from the monthly
survey of employers uh that is done
those are all New Hampshire jobs but as
a monthly survey that is released by
Bureau Labor Statistics and then the
next slides are using the administrative
records so actual reports filed by New
Hampshire employers so they're both
they're both reflective of New Hampshire
jobs but they are taken from two
different sources so they won't match up
perfectly but it it's our only way to
get into the specifics of how each
sector is faring
um when we look at where they currently
stand compared to where they were prior
to the pandemic
so the actual job creation is a more
accurate to look at the page
that that reflects the stats at 6600 so
the number of jobs created would be in
that range as opposed to yeah the the
these charts that are taken from the qcw
program so it's actual records filed by
employers those are the gold standard
those are actual records filed by
employers the problem with those
representative and why we tend to
utilize their survey data quite
frequently is the frequency that it's
produced in the lag that's involved with
it so with like a lot of government
sources of data it's a great resource
but it's old right so there's there's a
long lag with our qcew data by the time
um you know the employers don't file
that until the quarter is over
um it's it's not vetted and prepped and
able to be published until uh you know
another few months so there's there's
quite a lag and you want to know what's
going on in the interim but it's
it's as accurate as you can get and one
exercise that the department does as
each state does each year we're coming
up on that every February we actually
take that data that qcew data is filed
by employers and we go through what's
called a benchmarking process so we take
the actual wage records from employers
and we compare it against the survey
data that had been released monthly
throughout the year and that survey data
gets trued up to the actual reports so
when we published our the unemployment
rate when it comes out in February
towards the end of February we also
release benchmarked employment data so
it you'll see a an adjustment or
revision to all the monthly numbers and
um and so the um the slide with the
title percentage employment gains and
losses that's just trying to put those
numbers into perspective of how
significant they are for the particular
sector
um and then the next slide tries to put
that into perspective for how
significant it is from a total labor
force perspective in New Hampshire so
how much of the the labor force does
that particular sector lay claim to from
a number of jobs as a as a percentage of
total private sector employment or total
employment when we look at state
um moving on after those slides you'll
see there's a slide talking about
initial claims for unemployment benefits
so you know this will be a topic of
conversation that
um I'm sure we'll be having with regard
to proposals before this committee but
this gives you a sense this slide in the
next few slides give you a sense of
where the unemployment program is right
now so during the pandemic 175 000
people came in and visited us uh we paid
them benefits uh over two billion
dollars more benefits in a year and a
half than we paid out in the decade
prior to that combined but now you can
see that from a claims perspective New
Hampshire is in a much different place
than the rest of the country so our
initial claim filings and our continued
claim filings which I'll explain in a
minute are both significantly down
compared to pre-pandemic numbers which
when we compared a 2019 we thought those
numbers were pretty good
um you know unemployment was at about
2.7 percent I mean we thought things
were good well now you can see our
initial claim numbers are actually down
about 40 percent
from where we were representative
Schultz you have a question
thank you Mr chair to what degree does
this include people who
um at least temporarily left the job
market for any reason
and compared to without covid they would
have still continued to work does that
make sense my question make sense so
these and and also to what degree does
um so these numbers for the initial
claims only include those people that
were working in covered employment so
W-2 employment and lost their employment
through no fault of their own and were
eligible for unemployment benefits
um so that those are the numbers that
you see here the household survey number
that gets released each month we release
it next Wednesday for um that will be
the December unemployment rate that
number is based on the household survey
and so that's a survey of about 1400
households in New Hampshire Bureau Labor
Statistics conducts that survey the very
protective of it they don't let us do
anything with it don't ask let us ask
questions don't let us listen in very
protective of that we've had some
disagreements with them if you can tell
um
that's from that survey you find out
whether people are employed unemployed
or not in the labor force and so when
you see that rate come out right now New
Hampshire is at 2.6 percent unemployment
for November
that number reflects the people that
have indicated so if you're working
you're put in the employed bucket if
you're not currently working you're
unemployed but you're actively looking
for work meaning you've searched for
work during the prior four weeks you are
considered unemployed for purposes of
that that published number but if you
have not searched for work within those
last four weeks you're not in the labor
force for purposes of that particular
survey there are other surveys though
that get published different other
different types of unemployment rates
the the standard one that you see the
number every month is referred to as the
u3 rate there's I mean we have
information on our website for this if
you search under you to labor or under
utilization but you have a u4 u5 and a
U6 rate as well and each one of those
captures a different segment of the
population that is not working
and is frustrated to some degree either
they haven't searched in more than 12
weeks or they're working part-time but
would prefer full-time so that so each
of those captures more people that to
some degree would like to be in the
labor force or would like to participate
at a higher level and are not and that
rate that U6 rate usually Trends
um not quite double what the the u3 rate
is that you know it's up we're probably
five and a half percent
right now the U6 when you take in all
the all of those individuals who are not
actively looking but indicate that
they're like some level of employment
um self-employed
um would uh or should be captured in the
household survey
depending on what you feel
um
or how how you interpret the question
being asked right so if you're
self-employed and the question is are
you currently working and you don't
consider yourself to be working because
you're self-employed and doing your own
thing you might say no
but you should be saying yes you should
be indicating that you're employed a
better way to ask the question would be
are you are you currently providing
services for what you're being
compensated for probably be a more
accurate reflection in the answers they
get but self-employed should be captured
in that household survey as working
their self-employed are not eligible for
the unemployment program so you don't
see any of that reflected here although
they were eligible during the pandemic
in the federal program
okay
yep
uh in terms of the claims you mentioned
I think the number of claims have been
filed can you give us a number of claims
that are denied
yeah so the um the actual claim numbers
that you see here and I have the um
this gets reported out every week it's a
great high frequency measure
um that's why we look at it as much as
we do
um
but what you see is the number of claims
filed so the number of initial claims
filed and the number of
continued claims filed when we get to
that slide not all of those are eligible
right so some of those are denied
um and we can I can get you a current
breakdown of denials of those initial
claims and the continued claims but
those are people believing they're
eligible they've lost employment so
they've filed an initial claim a lot of
times that initial claim never turns
into a payable claim because the person
finds employment so they don't file that
weekly claim which is on on the next
slide but these are claims filed some of
which would not be eligible for benefits
so so
so just the sense of
is that half of the claims filed are are
denied
much less than that okay much less than
that again some of the information the
research is out there would suggest it
in the very high rate
um the the research that indicates
that the denials the number of claims
filed and the number of claims that
denied the denial rate is fairly High
yeah I've been we can we can get you
um that information certainly and then
look at the continued claims as well
yes I'd like to see that because that's
not you're not going to Discount what
you're saying representative that's
you folks don't know that I'm on uh one
of the positions they they give us
another paid position here as the
chairman of the committee you get to go
on the Employment Securities Advisory
Board and meet on a quarterly basis and
that's just not my indication that
in the last couple years that our our
percentage of declined or denied claims
is significant to the point of 50
percent
and we'll be able to get the most
current information on that as well
um the next slide looks at the other the
the weekly claims or what we refer to as
continued claims other people talk about
weekly claims or paid claims so these
are the claims filed
um each week while you are unemployed uh
for an individual that's seeking
unemployment benefits so you can see
here New Hampshire how we compare
against the country as a whole how we
compare against our neighbor to the
South and Massachusetts New Hampshire is
about 36 percent below our uh weekly
claim filing activity compared to where
we were prior to the pandemic
Massachusetts is about uh seven percent
Below in the country as a whole is about
16 below so the volume of claims being
filed in New Hampshire is uh
significantly below where we were in 19
but also significantly below what other
um next slide does a state comparison of
how average duration looks in each state
so how many weeks an individual is on
average filing for unemployment benefits
so New Hampshire we have 26 weeks
available and right now
um the quarterly average uh for Q3 of
last year was 10 that number's actually
when we look at it monthly we just got
the the monthly number for December
today and that number's down to 9.4
percent so that's the average number of
weeks that an individual files for and
that's right now we're looking at
about also nine percent of individuals
that file that actually exhaust their
benefits so actually file for the full
26 weeks that would be available to them
obviously conducting meeting work search
requirements they're able and available
they're meeting a all of those
requirements they're attending workshops
and sessions with the with the
department but very low percentage of
people that utilize all 26 weeks in that
average duration right now is actually
down to 9.4 but when we when we look at
the quarterly and we can compare states
to States you see that New Hampshire is
about fifth lowest in the country a
couple spots lower than Florida which
we're often compared against for a
duration perspective and looking at tax
rates
thank you Mr chairman um
as you recall we had a bill last year
that was trying to limit the number of
weeks
and based on the data that you're
showing here on this slide it would
appear that since we have some of the
lowest uh
number
of weeks that people are utilizing a
bill of that nature really is not needed
in New Hampshire would you agree
well based on the um
this data on duration and then looking
at the impacts on employers because
employers fund the system I think you'll
see New Hampshire is performing quite
well
um
probably probably the the biggest
control
um to the two controls on duration in
New Hampshire one is availability of
jobs job postings are up of 30 from
where they were prior to the pandemic
um so so there are available jobs uh for
folks across all sectors so that is a
control on duration but the other
control on duration is our weekly
benefit amount New Hampshire we max out
at 427 a week that is much lower when we
compare ourselves against other states
in the Northeast and when you look at
that in comparison to the average uh
private sector weekly wage it's about a
30 33 percent wage replacement rate so
that that does act as a control on
duration of unemployment
um so it's going to obviously limit how
selective someone is being after they've
they've lost employment no fault of
their own qualify for benefits and
they're seeking a new job and they're
required to do that as part of their
eligibility for their weekly claim but I
think those two factors function very
well to control the the duration
um shifting gears a little bit here on
just look at how employers are currently
faring as employers do fund 100 of the
unemployment program so and that's
that's funded through the payment of the
their quarterly uh taxes so based off of
their wages employers have an
experienced rate that is based off of
what we've paid out in benefits to their
workers what they've paid in in taxes
during the entire time that they are
registered as an employer in New
Hampshire they then
get a calculated experience rate at
which they then pay taxes on the first
fourteen thousand dollars in annual
earnings for each employee
so what you can see in these next few
slides you see that we've had a
tremendous amount of growth in employers
from looking at pre-pandemic to where we
are now and you can see the quarterly
numbers of register employers so first
quarter of 2020 we're at about 43 000
registered employers a third quarter of
2022 we're at about just over 52 000
employers
um
when we look at the experience
in terms of the tax obligations of those
employers on when we look at the next
slide and what has occurred from the
pandemic moving forward and compare that
back to the Great Recession you can see
that the average tax rates were much
higher during the Great Recession and
stayed much higher for a longer period
of time so we had four quarters that
were over 3.3 percent as an average tax
rate back in the Great Recession capped
out near 3.7 percent and you see that
our Max average tax rate from the
pandemic was about 40 percent below that
we were down at 2.3 percent
it has continued to come down at about
1.42 right now so again that's that's
the rate at which the employer pays on
the first fourteen thousand dollars in
annual earnings to each employee and
that rate actually is a is the average
rate is actually higher than experience
by most long longer established
Employers in the State uh reason for
that is because on the prior slide you
saw the growth in new employers so new
employers when they come in and they
register they get an automatic new
employer rate of 2.7 percent that's set
by Statute so when you have that amount
of growth and new employers all coming
in at 2.7 that does bring up the average
um so that that if you looked at an
average tax rate of employers that were
established in the state prior to the
pandemic that average would be much
assistant commissioner um
the
I was around in 2011 when we had to
increase the
wages I think it was either twelve
thousand or ten thousand and it was
moved up to fourteen thousand dollars
in comparing us with some of these other
states that have a lower tax burden do
they all are most States now utilizing
that 14 are they utilizing higher number
of weeks or lower just on average just
um it's a great segue to the next slide
so because
each state they the taxable wage bases
and the way that the experience rates
are calculated do vary from state to
state so when we try to equalize that
and get us in apples to Apple's
comparison state to state what we look
at is is total UI taxes paid by the
Employers in that state as a comparison
against total wages paid and you'll see
on the on the next slide
New Hampshire where at about
0.39 percent and you can see how that
Stacks up against the other states so
much lower than our New England
neighbors and you can see those states
that have a lower UI tax burden when you
do compare total UI taxes paid against
total wages paid
thank you
Mr McKenzie representative uh real quick
to give us an a sense of how much this
costs an employer so per employee in the
state of New Hampshire based on the tax
rate and of course this may vary based
on experience rating and things like
that what does the average employer pay
per employee
so with the the 1.42 and you had to ask
me this question because in my other
copy of the slides I actually had a
cheat sheet anticipating that question I
think the 1.42 percent translates to
um it's like either 198 or 199 dollars
per year per employee so 1.42 of 14 000
in annual wages so for each employee
that hits that 14
000 that that employer is paying about
two hundred dollars in taxes that year a
um and then um trust fund you know
that's a a topic that uh chairman
infantine and and the department
um review quite frequently
um but uh this slide that next slide
shows you how the trust fund
um is currently looking and we are at
about 358 million dollars in that
account uh right now
um at the start of the pandemic we're at
about 300 million
um considered solvent by federal
standards
um at that point I will tell you that
360 million is much more
um
realistically solvent when we look at
prior economic downturns and what that
has done to the unemployment trust fund
so that that all of the
information we've talked about so far
this morning is contributing to this
growth in the trust fund right more
employers
low weekly benefit payments going out
um so all of that and low duration all
of that contributes to the growth in the
trust fund the impact of the growth in
the trust fund and the impact of quick
growth in the trust fund is that as of
the fourth quarter of last year
employers were already getting
um
um tax rate reductions or fund balance
reductions as they're referred to in the
statute and again that's a statutory
solvency control that says all right the
fund is grow has reached a sufficient
level where we can slow growth we can
slow or lessen the amount of tax burden
on employers that are funding this so as
of the fourth quarter employers received
a half Point reduction
in their tax rates that continues for
this first quarter which is
traditionally the most expensive quarter
for them and what that does is for
example that new employer that starts
with that 2.7 percent rate that new
employer
The Experience rate stays 2.7 for that
employer for four quarters however when
we have these fund balance reductions
that employer gets knocked down to 2.2
percent if you are at 1.5 it knocks you
down to one percent so a significant
reduction to employers and again it's
because of the quick growth in the trust
fund um what that what that translates
to in terms of tax savings for those
employers for the fourth quarter in this
first quarter is about 28 million
dollars most of that from the first
quarter because that's when the Lion's
Share of of UI tax revenue does come in
so
um with hitting that uh Half Point
reduction and that's because the the
trust fund got up to 250 million and
held 250 million for all of the third
quarter and it has since stayed above
that that next threshold is 350 million
so if we stay at 350 million or above
employers get a full one percent
reduction and if we stay at 400 million
or above employers get a one and a half
percent reduction and that's the max
reduction that they get to their rates
um right now we're forecasted to hit the
to sustain the 350 to give employers a
one percent rate reduction
um it it could hit as early as the
second half of 23 but that also
obviously depends upon the uh severity
of any sort of economic downturn that we
experience economists are all telling us
it's 50 50. so if it is more significant
and there are more job losses which we
don't think there there will be
significant job losses during this next
downturn that we experience but if there
were it's more of a drain on the
unemployment trust fund then that would
obviously delay hitting any any future
triggers for higher level tax rate
reductions for employers but we we hit
the first one very quickly folks if
this is kind of complicated the first
time you hear it for all the new members
of the committee
um
watching all these graphs understanding
these different bogeys to hit and how it
affects the the rate
um it's very important from a standpoint
of the the goal obviously is to get
people off unemployment to have it when
they need it get them off as soon as
possible and make sure this trust fund
it gets to a certain level where it
needs to be because as you've seen just
in my tenure here in the legislature
we've had two major events
in 2011 and 2019
where we had a significant drawdown
on our trust fund now what happens if
the trust fund goes installment it did
for about a month or so in 2010. we have
to borrow from the United States
government
there's still there were some amazing
some of the states that were unprepared
um and took years if they haven't I
don't even know if California has gotten
their way out of paying back I don't
think they have any plans to ever get
out of paying that down back so it
obviously keeps the rate up so
you may say it's a little more
conservative but having gone through two
of these
um increasing those numbers has helped
the state
because it has the trust fund money so
it can
replenish it easier and keep the tax
rate down I know it's complicated he
said well if the first three quarters if
it does this and this go happens and
take another quarter away and we give
you this discount or whatever I I know
it's it's dope unattended it's Greek um
um
to you but if you have any questions
feel free they're always available for a
call and some of the veterans here so I
see a couple of them watching around and
I know it's kind of complicated but
actually makes sense and it kind of
works so just wanted to throw that in
and I also served on the unemployment
advisory committee for many years so
this is not
um what I what I didn't hear you say
um
is the impact uh
uh we are at about a 30 replacement rate
and that being the case when the average
weekly wage in New Hampshire is what a
thousand something
so the employers are getting uh benefits
uh because of fund but what would be the
impact if we would increase start
sharing some of those with the employees
to raise the replacement rate for
employees and you you didn't mention
that because they clearly it when you
look at the the numbers you calculate
all that a low rate helps the trust fund
correct
yeah it's certainly if you have less
disbursements coming out of the account
right it's better for the the balance in
the account
um if you were to increase the rates
increase tiers that'll
um you know that would have a a negative
impact on the trust fund balance uh not
I'm not suggesting it would have a
negative impact on trust fund
performance uh but but the balance in
the fund yes and those all those types
of things can be calculated out
um when you know we have a two-year
forecasts that we're looking at for
trust fund performance uh with uh
forecasted levels of unemployment claim
filing and so if there were you know if
this committee were discussing proposals
to increase the rates at which people
receive each week that's you know
information the department can generate
in terms of impact on on the trust fund
moving out and just final question where
we at in terms of New Hampshire's
pay as it relates to the rest of the
country from average so average benefit
average weekly benefit amount right now
is around
330. this sounds about right
um max is 427.
um
that 330 is uh lowest in New England
Maine is slightly above not that much
above New Hampshire Massachusetts
much higher
than New Hampshire
um but the the current average weekly
benefit amount where that uh Falls
um and that and state state to state I
can get you a chart
um showing you where that currently is
so the the lowest rate is 27 per week
um and the the way your rate is
calculated it's set by Statute so it is
based upon the amount of earnings that
you had in the 15 to 18 months prior to
you losing your job so the the bare
minimum earnings that you have to have
in order to be monetarily eligible for
unemployment benefits is at least twenty
eight hundred dollars during that base
period and you have to have earned
fourteen hundred dollars in at least two
quarters
so that twenty eight hundred dollars
earned over the course of 15 to 18
months would get you twenty seven
dollars a week
um and then the benefit amount obviously
it goes up along with your base period
earnings and that 427
um is the rate at which an individual
earning 41 500 during the base period
would receive or anyone receiving more
than that or anyone earning more than
thank you chairman Mr chairman can you
tell me how many people are currently on
unemployment right now and how many jobs
are available right now
um hot off the press so comes out every
Thursday at 8 30
um our current number of individuals
that filed an initial claim during the
most recently reported week which was
weekending January 7th was 501 that is
about 30 percent below the same week in
2019 number of individuals filing a
weekly claim
um there's a slightly longer lag this is
the week ending December 31st important
thing about the week ending December
31st is its school vacation week so you
have a bus drivers cafeteria workers
they're all filing as they are eligible
to do that number was
3158 that is up higher because it being
vacation week with more individuals
being eligible but when you compare
vacation week 22 against vacation week
in 19 that's about a 30 percent drop
um
n22 compared to 19. so that's current
filing numbers and that we that gets put
out every Thursday
I believe you also had a was one of your
questions and how many of the jobs are
how many jobs are available well I know
um we have sorry we have uh that we
publish a monthly job postings
um uh data I don't have that right here
but I can get it to you representative
we're about
think between 30 to 40 percent higher
and then the number of unique postings
amongst all New Hampshire employers so
that they're unique so if so if I post a
a position in the union leader and I'm
also posting it on indeed they're only
counting that position once but what I
can provide and I didn't include here
but it's very helpful is you can see the
number of unique postings by employer
by sector and by occupational type so
you can see how many postings there are
for registered nurses how many postings
there are for lnas how many postings
there are for retail sales so that's
information that we can provide really
it's good information uh to be able to
to take a look at and it also has it for
employers as well so you can see who's
recruiting heavily right now and but
those are those numbers are continue to
be much higher than they were prior to
um and then just a couple more things Mr
chairman just to give the members a
flavor of what we're what we do
um currently to try to assist
individuals that come into any of our
New Hampshire Works offices the American
job centers as they're also called the
one stops as they're also called but
these 12 offices located throughout the
state which Employment Security operates
but individuals coming in or seeking
services online or seeking Services by
telephone what are we currently doing
for them to help them connect with all
of these hiring employers well one of
the biggest things we're doing that is a
very easy way for employers and job
Seekers to connect is with the virtual
job fairs that we continue to do so
these next two slides you can see our
current schedule we have uh one today
started uh was going from 11 to 1 for
the Seacoast employers so we do them
regionally last year we did about 70 of
these over the course of the year had 11
000 job Seekers attend those 70 events
and so we've
started uh right away again with uh you
can see our January schedule our
February schedule and then when you turn
the Turn the Page you can see what an
individual experience is when they need
to register for one of those events so
it's a quick registration process
they are then they're able to do that on
virtual job
fairs.nh.gov they then receive
information from the Department which
assists with giving them a little bit of
of information so it's not intimidating
if you're
trying to join one of these virtual
events for the first time and then we do
the same for employers employers
register on the same site we do
information to them prior to the event
to let them get a better flavor of how
the how the virtual job fair works
but again we anticipate that these will
be the dominant way that we're
conducting job fairs for for 23
employers a very much
liked this format job Seekers are we're
actually seeing more
which one would expect
with a little bit of the softening of
the economy we're actually seeing more
job Seekers at these events right now
compared to late summer early fall it's
another nice high frequency indicator
you can you can compare a Seacoast event
from say January to a Seacoast event
from October of last year and you can
see how many job Seekers are showing up
but those those events continue to be
pretty well attended so we think it's a
great opportunity easy opportunity for
employers and job Seekers to connect
without having to worry about driving to
the gymnasium at their local Community
College finding parking taking time out
of the day to actually get there get
back and it's kind of a an easier way
for folks to connect so we will continue
to do those and with a mixture of
in-person events as well
um and then lastly a couple of pages on
um one of our job search portals one
this is one that we launched during the
pandemic but it's
nhjobs.nh.gov so this is a a
site that we host where employers are
able to post positions all of the
individuals coming in to utilize our
services or not utilize our services but
know about it and can go online and do
this are able to search for jobs on this
site on
nhjobs.nh.gov as well as our job match
system and then to get a sense of the
the types of jobs that are on there I
did
include a screenshot of one of them I'm
not suggesting that all of the jobs are
comparable to what Fidelity is
recruiting for it just so happens that I
printed out a Fidelity recruitment
position and they have been utilizing
this site in our services heavily coming
out of the pandemic and they've
experienced a lot of growth as has the
financial services sector so just again
to give folks a a sense of
what we're currently doing to try to
assist people with getting back to work
and then I also did include one slide on
our work now program this is the program
that we provide one-on-one case
management for individuals as well as we
pay for their training we pay for their
transportation but individuals that are
enrolled in Medicaid Medicaid expansion
TANF snap this is a program that we
currently operate out of all of those
One-Stop centers very high participation
we enroll usually between 20 25 people
per week they work one-on-one with folks
in those one stops we help them with
vocational direction we continue to meet
with them they go into training we pay
the trainer for that and we actually pay
their transportation costs while they're
while they're enrolled so another type
of program another example of what we do
from the employment services side to
help folks
you got to fill that position of ice
cream it appeared and make everyone
Mr McKenzie representative Mackenzie
um some years ago the state made a
decision to separate out the workforce
opportunity Council from the
jurisdiction I don't know if it was
under the
under the employment security
but that uh they are absent here today
but that is a whole component of the
training of work is within the state of
New Hampshire and so is a system that's
currently separated there are two in two
different entities and the thing about
the
um if I may Mr chairman the thing about
the workforce opportunity Council it is
a separate entity in and of itself it's
not under government state government
it's not another jurisdiction or the
labor committee or the legislature
basically operates on its own given that
is somewhat of a different model from
other states and given that you have the
responsibility for the training and
placement of workers does it make sense
to start the discussion
um around bringing that back under the
guise of the Department of Employment
Security
and to to give you the flexibility you
have a full range of opportunities for
workers to tap into
and the reason is just a matter of
History the reason as I recall was
separated is because they wanted to be
able to move quickly and that they said
that they fed the state government kind
of slowed the opportunity of them to
deliver programs so do you have any
opinion
competitors I think you worked for the
workforce opportunity I'm going to
deflect this one to my boss yeah
yeah I mean
right now I mean it comes under uh
business and economic Affairs that's
where it's located at this point in time
but at one point it was and and uh I
mean you know that's up to the
legislature whether or not they'd want
to move I mean we've got a great working
relationship with uh business and
economic Affairs I mean we partner with
them on all the job fairs and it's you
know right now it's everything we do
yep but they have no further question
but they are outside of the the uh the
state structure in terms of of oversight
but a labor Committee of the legislature
um I would I mean I think you know they
fall under business and economic Affairs
if they have yeah correct they have
their own board the board is I mean it's
a 33 person board that oversees and they
to uh to the people and it's open
meetings if anybody wants to go to those
and there are um representative there
are programs that we we administer
Under the wioa Umbrella so the workforce
Innovation Opportunity Act umbrella
federally funded uh programs for
training that we operate those jointly
with Bea through the office of Workforce
opportunity because they are the the
recipient of those wioa dollars and then
they designate Employment Security to
run the dislocated worker program so
that's another program that we
administer with individuals losing
employment we're able to pay for some
pay for training and other supports
while they search for work that's that's
within that umbrella of programs that
you talk about and then Southern New
Hampshire Services actually operates the
adult program
um and they and they do that they
operate that out of all of the New
Hampshire Works offices the one stops
that we talk about so we work quite
closely with them in administering those
programs this work now program that we
included information on is a purely
state funded state-run program but it
works in conjunction and with those wioa
Federal training programs because we we
are obligated to pay federal training
dollars before we put State training
dollars forward so those those two
programs get stacked together for
individuals
we have to wrap this up but um I thought
I would recommend the folks go on the
department of unemployment Securities
website there's a lot of information
there's a lot more things they do
trading Services uh just to become aware
the only question I have is
you um are very good about providing
benefits to individuals when they come
to you to try to do it as quickly as
possible and then sometimes you find out
individuals that applied and received
benefits did not qualify
and you're in that situation now where
you have a number of individuals can you
tell us what kind of a backlog you have
on the hearings for individuals that
you've determined that or it's your
opinion that they receive benefits they
did not uh
qualify
um so from a a hearing perspective so
individuals that
um just the hearings that people get are
those that when they disagree with that
determination that they get we have an
extensive administrative appeal
structure that goes all the way up to
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
um there there currently is no backlog
on those hearings so if you disagree
with being denied benefits
um
um you know
it was you thought the the separation
was the employer's fault
um it was determined it was your fault
through something that you you a
position that you quit but you you were
determined not to be unemployed through
no fault of your own
um those hearings are getting scheduled
in less than 30 days from when that
point from when that is filed so those
are are meeting all timeliness standards
as imposed on states by the federal U.S
Department of Labor
um so we're very good there that's not
the case with other states still dealing
with a pandemic backlog still looking at
paying people pandemic unemployment
assistance so some struggles there with
other states but we're caught up from
that perspective individuals that
receive benefits that should not have
and this is a a topic that does come up
for a conversation
um with with this body so right now if
your paid benefits that you should not
have been paid in the Department's
screwed up right we put you on the wrong
program we incorrectly adjudicated your
separation as qualifying when in fact it
wasn't or maybe maybe the employer
didn't provide us some information as
quickly as they should have
um when we find that out and it is
determined that you are not eligible but
it's not because anything you did you
thought you were eligible you filed your
claim and you were paid you are found
overpaid but it's not your fault so you
are without fault and you don't have to
repay those benefits okay so those
individuals they're they're not eligible
they are not eligible to continue to
file but they don't have to pay the
benefits back and they can they can
appeal right that eligibility
determination if they disagree with it
however if you file and you're paid and
it is determined that you are paid
through some sort of misrepresentation
and information that you provided to us
or didn't provide and it was reasonable
to think that you should have you would
again be found overpaid and in those
circumstances it would be your fault you
would be on the hook for repaying those
benefits it's a civil decision we have
mechanisms for ensuring that you repay
it we try to get people into payment
agreements when they don't do that we we
garnish wages we garnish your federal
tax income tax refund but that's a civil
decision
um
we do have situations where people
intentionally lie to us right they
intentionally misrepresent going back to
work having earnings when they go back
to work they file they are eligible when
they file but then they get another job
and they don't tell us about it despite
us asking on those weekly continued
claims are you working are you earning
any money they tell us nothing they go
on for several weeks those individuals
are found to have committed fraud they
are found overpaid the more egregious
cases get prosecuted in conjunction with
a uh unemployment insurance prosecutor
that is housed in the criminal Bureau at
the Department of Justice paid for by
this agency so those occasionally you'll
see those in the newspaper on those more
egregious cases the people failed to
report earnings and work and continue to
file for unemployment we go after those
people quite aggressively because we
want to make sure people are aware that
it's a serious crime and it's that you
need to to take your responses to those
questions on your weekly claim very
seriously other individuals that have
engaged in that type of conduct not as
egregious but again they misrepresented
to us they would have a civil fraud
decision again have to repay it we have
various mechanisms for collecting that
but it's not something that we would go
after criminally so that's an ongoing
issue
regardless of how much activity we have
of trying to educate people when they
come in to file
it always occurs it happens in every
state and we we do our best to detect it
early to have as minimal impact on the
trust fund and then we aggressively
pursue collection with individuals that
have engaged in that type of conduct
some quick questions because we're
behind representative Schultz
do you keep track of the percentage of
no fault
um employees and do you keep track of
the number of redeterminations
of amount
employees are paid you know the re I
think that's the name of when you
refigure what a rate is per employee do
you keep track of redeterminations per
um so the overpayments for no fault
versus fault yes we have that
information we can provide that to you
the the redeterminations are you talking
about redetermining a benefit amount or
yes
um they're probably multiple reasons
certainly if your office discovers the
no fault situation
you can issue that redetermination on
your own as an office but also if
someone takes temporary jobs as their
unemployed technically you know that
often results in a redetermination
especially if the rate is different with
a different employer
okay that's I see where you're going now
sorry about that
um so what happens is so New Hampshire
allows individuals to have part-time
work and part-time earnings while
they're collecting unemployment benefits
um you can't be working full-time and we
and there is a limit to what you can
earn and still receive an unemployment
benefit so what's required of everybody
um when they are filing for unemployment
on that weekly claim they answer the
questions as to whether they are whether
they worked during the week claimed and
what they had for earnings during that
week claimed we then take those reported
earnings and they may or may not
function as an offset against your
weekly benefit amount so you're allowed
to earn 30 of your weekly benefit amount
without it impacting your weekly benefit
amount anything above 30 percent then
functions as a dollar for dollar draw
down on your weekly benefit amount that
calculation gets done your weekly
benefit amount that rate doesn't change
but for that particular earlier week
that you had earnings it would be the
the check you receive could be less and
it would be calculated based upon what
you had in earnings anything over 30
percent would be a dollar for dollar
drop
ped
um what else I'm sorry if I didn't
entirely agree and I
um understand if someone takes a
temporary job for a week or two and then
is unemployed again it doesn't that
amount for those two weeks impact their
new create a new rate of unemployment
it does not create a new rate the your
rate is purely a function of the
earnings that you had during your base
period so your base period is the first
four uh completed quarters of the last
five okay so that those are the earnings
that we look at for calculating out your
weekly benefit amount now the part-time
job that you take the earnings from that
can influence your weekly benefit amount
based on the calculation I just reviewed
also if you have a disqualifying
separation from that job that you take
that can also impact your ongoing
eligibility for benefits as well that
so you know other questions thank you
very much gentlemen I appreciate
um Representatives you can always uh you
have their business cards you can always
call them if you have any uh particular
questions
thank you very much
um we're going to take a three or four
minute break just so people can go to
the bathroom or not and then come back
uh gentlemen if you'd like to approach
approach the bench and uh we'll be right
with you in a couple minutes because Mom
equipment
happy
birthday yeah there is because of what
he was saying we were unemployed for a
long time but this incentive to take a
we're gonna get started folks if you can
take your seats
assistant commissioner Ogden welcome
thank you representative infantine and
thanks for asking us to come over and
speak so uh representative infantine had
called us last week and said uh that
there'd be some benefit uh perhaps of
the apartment coming over and doing a
little bit of an operational overview of
what the department does looking around
the room and speaking with you a couple
of you I know that some of you know
everything that we do and have been
around and seen what the Department's up
to longer than even I have uh that being
said I think it's always a good and
welcome opportunity to sit down and talk
and say what we do maybe talk a little
bit about what we don't do
um but then also happy to take any
questions I did walk around and just put
a very simple handout
um that's more to keep us ordered and to
keep making sure that I hit all of the
points or the issues that we wanted to
raise just in terms of what we're going
to do we're going to walk through the
operation of the Department of Labor
chiefly we're going to talk about the
two divisions we have a Workers
Compensation Division we have an
inspection division we have a hearings
Bureau and then we have the
Administration or Office of the
commissioner again when we talk about
the Department of Labor and workers
compensation really what we're talking
about is the department administers and
regulates the workers compensation
system in the state of New Hampshire
that's an all-involved type of task and
what I mean by that is we do everything
from working with employers and carriers
to ensure that coverage is in place
that's something that we always like to
highlight that it's a requirement in New
Hampshire that if an employer has even
one person working part-time that
employer needs workers compensation
coverage that workers compensation
coverage needs to be secured through a
carrier who then reports that to the
department in terms of how coverage is
reported to the department I don't want
to bore folks with that but I do want to
just highlight essentially workers
compensation coverage is reported to the
department through ncci workers
compensation carriers they
electronically submit their policies to
ncci and then those policies or ncci
then submits to the department based
basically every day a data feed saying
okay this is the reporting we have on
coverage we work with employers and what
I mean by that is we have ways in which
we say Okay an employer is now reporting
employees to Employment Security and
they don't have workers compensation
coverage on file so that it might
initiate contact or a call from the
Department we also sometimes look into
issues where we see coverage has fallen
off so if we have an employer that has
always held coverage in New Hampshire
and then for whatever reason their
coverage falls off we would reach out to
them again the reason for coverage is
very important without coverage those
costs can be quite significant and they
actually can be held personally against
the employer additionally and more
importantly without coverage you have
instances in which the injured worker if
they have medical bills or if there's a
period of Indemnity there's the
potential for those to not be able uh to
be covered or paid for because again the
cost can sometimes become pretty
astronomical
in addition to coverage through workers
compensation carriers or insurance
companies we also regulate and permit
self-insurance for purposes of workers
compensation it's something that
oftentimes I don't think comes up too
often in this committee but workers
compensation self-insurance that's under
RSA 281 a5a and what you're talking
about there is that employers in New
Hampshire or groups of employers in New
Hampshire they have the option of saying
that they want to self-insure for
workers comp they say they can actually
provided that they have sufficient
financials and are able to demonstrate
certain things they can essentially say
that they will pay for workers
compensation through self-insurance as
opposed to securing a carrier or a
policy rather with a carrier workers
compensation self-insurance again I
reference the fact that there can be
groups of employers so you have some
individual employers that are big enough
and have the financial wherewithal to do
it on their own you also have groups of
employers and in New Hampshire the
system or program calls for them to be
homogeneous so you could have a we for
instance we have a lumber Industries
group and what this is is it's a group
of lumber companies or companies
associated with the lumber trade or
Lumber industry who've come together in
a group and they actually go out and
hire a third party administrator they
get bonding they do other things and
essentially they set up a workers
compensation coverage program again
self-insured for the benefit of the
subscribing members
the next bullet you'll see is talking
about peos or professional employer
organizations sometimes it's referred to
as Employer leasing employee leasing
employee leasing is a term that a lot of
folks don't like nowadays but it still
sometimes referred to as that these are
organizations where it's essentially a
co-employment model where you might have
an entity that works with workers and
for whatever reason they decide well
they no longer want to be necessarily
the employer of record they want people
doing work for them but they want to
kind of offshore the payroll processes
and the benefits processes and things of
that nature and there are actually
companies out there these peos that they
provide those types of services ADP is a
big one of these ADP provides a whole
umbrella of services but one of the
things a company like ADP will do is
they will provide uh you know peo
Services the Department of Labor we
license POS or permit peos in this state
diverse reports of injury when people
hear about workers compensation
obviously and unfortunately I think they
most often think so think of folks
getting hurt and really the first report
of injury Point that's something very
important that the department does on an
annual basis we typically receive
reporting of over 40 000 workplace
injuries now these workplace injuries
are not all horrific because again
employers should be reporting all
injuries whether
um you know it's something that you know
is is significant requiring Hospital
time over at something more minor but
again on an annualized basis we're
typically receiving first reports of
injury of over 40 000 reports a year
something that sometimes comes up with
first reports of injury so if we look at
the statute 281 a53 it's talking about
there is a timeliness component to that
these injury reports are supposed to be
filed Timely
basically within five days if they're
not file timely the department will
follow up I would note that the
obligation ultimately rests with the
employer that being said most employers
as I referenced earlier they have a
carrier they have an insurance carrier
that they've contracted with and the
carrier is oftentimes the one that's
reporting those injuries but I would
point out that if there's a problem in
the reporting we ultimately do go to the
employer and say hey this needs to be
corrected this is something that you
need to look at
um claims it's kind of an all-inclusive
term and what I mean by that is we have
a claims unit at the Department of Labor
that's essentially tasked with uh
administering uh the benefit sections of
281a and what I mean by that is if there
is a claim so again I said when I said
we get 40 000 reports of injury not all
of those ripen into claims I would say
the vast majority of injuries that
reported they end up not ripening
ripening into claims where there's
Indemnity or medical or anything like
that but those that do become claims
those have to be administered and what I
mean by administered is throughout 281a
there are certain requirements that the
carrier you know the carriers on the
hook for certain things the employees on
the hook to do certain things in terms
of providing medical information and
other things of that nature and our
claims unit works with folks both the
carriers the employers and the Injured
Workers in order to make sure that
things are properly administered
the next Point you'd have is dispute
resolution one of the things that I
think that we're most proud of over the
last few years that we've done is we've
actually put in place someone who works
full-time as a dispute resolution
coordinator if you look at RSA 281 a42
it talks about the fact that the
Department's going to have on staff
someone that can assist Pro Se or
Injured Workers and when I say assist
this person in this position is actually
set up to fully work with Pro Se
employees those who are not represented
by an attorney and help them walk
through the system and get information
and that's something that we've really
we've done over the last two years the
person we have in that position now it's
a full-time position and we've gotten a
lot of good feedback from Injured
Workers if even from carriers because
the person in this position sometimes
it's not always about fighting sometimes
it's about just getting people
communicating and getting people on the
same page and understanding what
conversation should be happening
um when I talk about dispute resolution
ultimately If things cannot be resolved
sometimes they will go to hearings
so I'll talk a little bit about our
hearings Bureau on a broader basis but
uh through workers compensation we do
anywhere from 1200 to 1800 hearings a
year and what I mean by hearings is
these are actual issues in which there's
ultimately been a dispute whether it be
that the worker wants to assert benefits
or that there's been a denial from the
carrier if they're not able to come to
some type of agreement or accommodation
on those types of things it could
actually go to a full-fledged formal
hearing where the parties would sit in
front of a hearings officer they'd put
forth what their what their case is and
then the department ultimately issues a
decision in addition to hearings on what
we would call a first level Hearing in
front of a departmental hearings officer
where administratively attached to the
compensation appeals board or the
compensation appeals board is
administratively attached to the
department and the compensation appeals
board serves as a secondary level to
basically if there's been a first level
hearing after which one of the parties
feels grieved they can then appeal that
to the compensation appeals board the
compensation appeals board is set up of
33 members where you have 11
representatives from labor 11
representatives from employers and then
11 employers or carriers and then 11
representatives from neutrals and those
are essentially attorneys who typically
chair the panels and would assist in
writing the decision
after the compensation appeals board
renders a decision and those are de novo
hearings and that's something that I
point out because sometimes folks will
have an appeal at the first level and
they'll be unsatisfied if you appeal it
to the compensation appeals board it is
a de novo hearing meaning that it starts
Anew and the parties have a fresh
opportunity to dispute the case if
there's a still appeals uh coming from
the compensation appeals boards those
actually go up to the Supreme Court
uh the other thing I would reference
relative to workers compensation or our
administration of the system is our
administration of funds there's a very
second injury fund if you look at RSA
281 a55 the second injury fund is this
program
um it's basically our evolving fund
where it's not it's not money that's
come in and held by the department for
the departmental purposes essentially
the second injury fund is this fund that
has been set up to say that if in an
instance you have an employee who
suffered a second injury so they had a
period a first injury for which there
was a period of disability and then
through their work they have then a
second injury the second injury fund
basically says that the uh carrier or
employer whose uh basically paying
compensation or benefits for that second
injury second injury they would perhaps
be entitled to seek reimbursement from
the second injury fund it's some way of
mitigating what might be uh exacerbated
costs for a second injury the second
injury fund again when I say it's a
revolving fund what we do is we take in
the request for second injury fund
reimbursement on an annualized basis
once we have those requests come into
the department if we say that that
number and it can be pretty significant
it could be upwards of the highest that
it's been since I've been there as there
was a year that it was around 20 million
dollars
when those uh when we say that there
might be upwards of 20 million dollars
uh in in reimbursement we then put out
an assessment that is uh paid by workers
compensation carriers writing in the
state of New Hampshire that they're
assessed on a pro-rata basis meaning the
percentage of payouts that they uh
issued in workers comp on this for the
State uh that would be their
attributable amount for these assess for
this assessment the money then comes
back into the department the department
then disperse disperses that money to
the carriers seeking reimbursement so
that's why I said it's a revolving fund
it's not something it's the 20 million
dollars it doesn't hit the Department's
budget in terms of departmental
expenditures it's instead a revolving
fund that we assessed
um and pay out of uh for again
reimbursement for second injury funds
the other is the administration fund the
Department of Labor's finances we are a
general fund contributor and what I mean
by that is we do not draw on General
funds we used and utilize no General
funds our uh the Department's finances
are instead driven by two Revenue
sources the first is referenced here is
the administration fund and essentially
what the department does is for its
costs of administering the workers
compensation chapter we uh come up with
a number of okay that's what that costs
and again there is then an assessment of
the workers compensation carriers
writing in New Hampshire and they pay
their Pro rat a share the other
Revenue source is the restricted fund
and the restricted fund is made up of
all revenue that the department collects
through its fines fees licenses and
things of that nature not to bore you
with it but how essentially the
department does its finances as we take
in the administration fund we we take in
the restricted fund we then pay
everything we have to pay in terms of
salaries expenditures all of those
things whatever is left over then goes
back to the general fund
um as basically a contribution
the last thing I've listed relative to
workers compensation is uh Daniel Albert
is the current director of workers comp
and I've put her name in number
Danielle's work for the Department
almost as long as I have about 10 years
she's been a hearing officer she's been
one of our attorneys and now she's the
director of workers comp I just
highlight her to you as a great resource
and I encourage you if you have workers
comp questions if you have constituents
who have workers comp questions anything
of that nature feel free to reach out to
her really at any time and like I said
we'll work to get you answers on those
issues sometimes workers comp can be
pretty cumbersome I do know there are
folks who you know it's a time where
they're in a vulnerable place and when
they get denials they get very upset and
it's oftentimes hard to then look and
say okay how do I navigate this system
when do I submit things how do I submit
things what do I need to submit we're
happy to walk through walk folks through
all of that additionally it's not just
Injured Workers we're happy to work with
we're happy to work with the employers
and as well and the carriers again it
truly is one of those situations in
which everyone needs to understand what
the requirements are and it always works
better if people understand those things
and there's good communication and
conversation around it
as I said we're principally made up of
two divisions the inspect the workers
comp division the second is the
Inspection Division the Inspection
Division A lot of times I think what
people traditionally think of when they
think of Departments of Labor the
Inspection Division has a couple of
primary focuses the first is wage an
hour wage and hour is what we refer to
and we talk about really our inspection
activities relative to employers it's
what you think about when you think
about are people getting paid on time
are they being paid in full are they
being paid properly in terms of the
statutes that we administer there's this
overarching around RSA 275 is protective
legislation
if you look at RSA 275 that's really
talking about the payment parameters in
terms of again when someone has to be
paid the form and format of payment it
also talks about some of the other
protective measures that are in place
relative to you know people being paid
in a certain way people
um having certain requirements related
to if you're you know when you can
prorate a salary things of that nature
so that's RSA 275 RSA 279 is what we
call New Hampshire's minimum wage law
for those folks that don't know and I
think most of you do but New Hampshire
doesn't have an exact minimum wage in
the sense so New Hampshire has not
identified its own minimum wage instead
what New Hampshire does through our say
279 is it tracks to the federally
stated minimum wage additionally I
always point out when we talk about
minimum wage law the Department of Labor
does not actually deal with a lot of
instances in which folks are being paid
less than minimum wage and I would say
most employees we actually deal with are
being paid well in and in addition to
what minimum wages are minimum wage
issues chiefly relate to if you look at
RSA 279 26b or 21 uh where it's talking
about tipped Wages that's where most of
the issues come up when we're talking
about RSA 279 because the tipped laws or
laws related to tipped employees they
fall under RSA 279 so to be clear we
don't see a lot of minimum wage issues
in terms of people not being paid
minimum wage we do though come across
quite a number of issues related to how
tips are handled or mishandled
um youth labor is under RSA 276 a
um the thing I always highlight when I
talk about youth labor to folks is
there's really two categories in New
Hampshire you have
um anyone so you a lot of times you'd
say 14 and 15 year olds and then you
have 16 and 17 year olds 14 and 15 year
olds there's also federal regulations
and the Federal Regulations are somewhat
or slightly stricter than New
Hampshire's law
for 16 and 17 year olds there are not
federal limitations on hours but there
are State limitations so I always point
that out to folks is that you're talking
about really 16 and 17 14 and 15 and
having some awareness of the fact that
14 and 15 year olds there's also Federal
standards when we're talking about youth
labor you're really talking about mainly
what can kids do so there's certain
prohibited occupations we have adopted
Federal standards for hazardous orders
which essentially say kids cannot do
certain things they can in certain
instances if they're part of an
apprenticeship program if they're or
part of a vocational learning program
but absent that there are certain
occupations or tasks that youth are
strictly prohibited from doing in
addition to prohibitions about
occupations or tasks they can't do we're
really talking about hours we're talking
about you know kids can only work so
many hours in a week so many hours in a
day and things of that nature there were
legislative changes last session that
slightly raised the hours that that
youth could work but but again that's
something to be aware of and when we're
talking about youth labor issues that's
really what it is is our kids working
too many hours or uh you know doing too
many hours during school and things of
that nature the only other thing I bring
up with youth labor is there are certain
documentation requirements so if you're
an employer who's hiring 14 and 15 year
olds you need a youth certificate form
if you're hiring during 16 and 17 year
olds you need a parental permission form
I also would highlight this is several
rounds of several sessions ago but there
was a change that allowed parents can
now fill out the youth certificate used
to have to have been filled out by the
school district now parents can fill out
the youth certificate so that's just
something I point out is that whether
it's a youth certificate or whether it's
a parental permission form parents can
fill that out but those are documents
that have to be in place at or right
around the time of hire for youth
workers
the warn act
um the Warren actus uh 275 app and
commissioner capatus who you who you
just saw he's the commissioner of
Employment Security he had previously
been the commissioner of Labor and when
he was the commissioner of Labor uh
bless you when he was the commissioner
of Labor he had actually I believe
championed the um putting in of the uh
the state Warren act the Warren act
essentially what we're talking about is
if you have a company and it's a defined
there's a threshold it has to be an
employer of 100 or more but if you have
an employer subject to the warn act that
is uh engaging in a mass layoff event so
if they're hiring a certain threshold
number of people or they're closing a
facility they need to provide advance
notice to those workers and to the
department and to the Attorney General's
office and to their local Authority and
if they don't they could potentially be
liable for upwards of 60 days of wages
which is essentially that notice period
so that's something that comes up from
time to time lastly in terms of wage an
hour or I would highlight citizens job
protection
under 275 a that is the requirement that
says that an employer needs to have a
certain author they need to basically
have authorization documentation showing
that that individual employee is
authorized to work in the in the United
States prior to hire the other thing I
would talk about when I reference
citizen job protection sometimes the
question comes up
um about whether that's a penalty
against it's not a penalty or there's
not penalties against the worker in
question this is a requirement that the
employer is obligated to look at and say
okay they need the documentation it's
not something that's held against the
worker
in addition to wage and hour the
Inspection Division administers certain
safety programs
first RSA 277 is safety or worker safety
for public employees one thing I would
highlight is we absent what I'll
reference below with 281 a64 we have
very limited a very limited role
relative to worker safety for private
employment that is covered by federal
OSHA but for public employees those
folks who work for cities towns the
state things of that nature the
Department of Labor has oversight
Administration
responsibilities relative to enforcing
certain safety standards
um we conduct inspections
um we will follow up and seek
remediation and things of that nature
under 281 a64 that applies to both
private and public employers and 28164
is essentially some fairly
straightforward safety requirements
saying that employees or subject
employers who have 15 or more they have
to basically 15 or more employees in
this state they have to file a safety
summary form and they have to uh and
panel a joint Loss Management committee
which is a committee that the employer
should make have made up that basically
looks at safety issues relative to their
operation
um in addition to wage now or in safety
we also under RSA 157a and 157b we have
boilers an elevator oversight
um these are basically uh not in private
instances these are for commercial
applications or non-residential
again I've put there the point of
contact uh Lexi Rojas is the director of
the Inspection Division and again
questions if your constituents or you
have questions relative to those types
of topics that I've referenced above I
encourage you uh to reach out to Lexi
one thing I wanted to also bring up
relative to inspection because our
Inspection Division does get quite a bit
of attention and a lot of you know
questions because that is the arm of the
organization that does conduct our
inspections so that's the group that
when we have complaints we would go out
and do an inspection and I just want to
talk very briefly about what is
inspection entails and then kind of the
follow-up from an inspection so
essentially as I reference where
principally complaint driven we don't
have to be we do have the authority
under law to go in and and and look at
any employer's operation but uh for at
least as long as I've been there and I
think even decades before the department
is complaint driven so essentially we're
having people call us and say whether
something's happening or not happening
and based on what they're saying
um you know we try to do some filtering
in terms of looking okay is this a good
complaint I know sometimes folks will
say we get bad complaints but we try to
do what we can to get to okay is this a
valid good faith complaint if we do then
we would and do an inspection and
basically what an inspection is is we
would send one of our compliance folks
one of our labor inspectors they would
visit the employer they'll give a notice
saying okay this is what I'm looking for
in terms of documentation and then based
on what they're given via documentation
based on what they're hearing being
employee interviews or interviews with
the employees and employers ultimately
what they're doing is coming back with
findings and saying hey whether they
feel there's been a violation whether
there's been no violations
if there are violations there are
sometimes penalties relative to
penalties and I'll talk about this in a
bit when I'm talking about our hearings
Bureau but prior to penalties being
issued RSA 27311 actually specifically
calls out that absent certain violations
employers are entitled to a warning and
what I mean by that is that it's not
something where it's looking to be a
gotcha if we do an inspection and the
employer has not yet had a warning
unless it's one of these certain topics
such as non-payment where they're not
entitled to a warning the employer would
get a warning we then have an
opportunity for the parties again the
parties being the department and the
employer to settle out and basically go
say what is the compliance concern if
there is one how does the employer come
into the compliance if there's penalties
we can work on the penalties we are
seeking the full payment of the wages
and what I mean by that is if we do an
inspection and we find that money is
owed to employees we're not looking to
reduce and will not reduce wages we will
work with employers on penalties but the
hearings Bureau so as I said we have our
Inspection Division Our Workers
Compensation Division we then have our
hearings Bureau that I just want to
highlight and what I'm highlighting
there is the fact that essentially as I
said earlier the department you know
ultimately a lot of what we do if we're
not able to come to some type of
agreement or settlement or parties or
not able to come type some type of
agreement or settlement that can
ultimately result in a hearing and in
our hearings Bureau is the is the arm of
the organization that essentially
processes those hearings we have workers
compensation hearings those are
happening basically Monday through
Friday
where essentially parties not the
department but parties whether it be an
employer or their carrier in the injured
worker they're coming in and sitting in
front of a hearings officer to deal with
their with their disputes relative to
the payment of benefits the payment of
medical bills things of that nature we
also hear wage claims
um I will point out relative to wage
claims that wage claims are not
something that's brought on the
Department's own motion employees in
this state actually have the individual
right to on their own motion say that
they feel that they're owed money they
can file a wage claim with the
Department if they file a wage claim
with us what we do with that is we then
turn around and give that to the
employer and say okay employer uh you
know Joe or Jane Smith has filed this
wage claim do you object to it if they
object we then go back to the claimant
say do you want to proceed with the
hearing if they don't object and they
don't answer at all we would say to the
claimant do you want to proceed with the
hearing the parties can then have a
hearing uh ultimately which there could
be an order for payment essentially
saying if there's wages owed there could
be a enforceable order for payment we
also under RSA 275e we process
whistleblower claims so if a
whistleblower in the state of New
Hampshire wants to assert certain rights
they can file a whistleblower claim with
the department they can also take those
claims to Superior Court but they can
file them with the Department of Labor
additionally and as I referenced earlier
relative to our inspection activities
there is sometimes based on what we do
or what we see or don't see there can be
civil penalties if we have civil
penalties we ultimately to enforce those
would have to go to a hearing the
hearing is an opportunity for the the
parties to put their cases forward and
ultimately again there could be an order
for payment of penalties if there's a
violation found I've also put here the
hearings and rules administrator Sarah
Fuller her contact information again if
you if you yourself or your constituents
have questions about hearings that are
either happening or not happening at the
department you could certainly reach out
to Sarah
and then lastly just in terms of points
of contact I'm just putting uh my name
and number
um in the commissioner's name and number
I've worked with most of you before I'm
always happy to take questions anytime
anyone calls we work to get folks
answers quickly if I don't know the
answer will work to get someone who does
know the answer
um next to me is Wes Gardner he's our
general counsel also very responsive and
then commissioner Merrifield who
unfortunately couldn't be here today but
commissioner Merrifield also very
responsive always happy to hear from
folks and like I said we really are
interested in hearing from folks hearing
what their concerns are I know several
of you on the committee we have worked
with in different capacities in terms of
concerns have come up constituent
concerns have come up so we're always
happy to work through those things at
any time so I know that that was a lot
very quickly but I just wanted to kind
of again highlight some of what we do
the only other thing I point out is to
always be aware of is there's certain
things like I said we don't do the U.S
Department of Labor handles certain
things such as Ada the U US Department
of Labor they handle like or you know
certain erisa questions
um they were already here but Employment
Security they handle unemployment so
there's certain things we don't do but
that's like I said if people call us on
those things we'll always be happy to
put them in the right direction but I
always point out because sometimes it's
not you know people are unsatisfied if
they call us and we're not able to
provide it direct assistance so happy to
answer any questions or thoughts or
concerns
um
I'm sorry I didn't see a representative
Sullivan
with regard thank you for taking my
question
um with regard to the inspectors do you
have different inspectors for each
category or are the cross-trained for
doing all kinds of inspections it's
different for different categories so we
have what we would call wage and hour
inspectors and then we have safety
inspectors then we have boiler and
boiler inspectors and elevator
inspectors thank you
I would say that there are certain
instances in which
um a wage and hour inspector might cite
a save if they go in and they're seeing
that there's uh no joint Loss Management
committee they might cite that
um so there is some overlap but
generally they they're into they're in
representative McKenzie
uh this committee over the years has
spent a lot of time in independent
contractors so I'd be interested to hear
um what the progress we've made over the
years in terms of reigning that
practicing
no it's a good question there's a lot of
work that's gone into that
um I will say I think that there are
still a lot of problems I will say that
in some ways I think the model has
changed and what I mean by that is even
when I started at the Department of
Labor it would be that we went to a job
site and it used to be that we were told
no none of them are employees they're
all independent contractors we're
typically not told that anymore the last
I want to say four or five years really
what we've been told and when I say we
the inspectors who've been at the job
sites
so I've gone to some of the job sites
and I've been told this as well is now
they will tell us oh no they're all
employees
and then we'll say Okay Everyone's an
employee but then when you follow up
with the inspection those employees are
actually not on payroll uh those
employees uh you know are being paid but
it might be being paid under the table
but I just point that out because the
misclassification I think it's it's
still a problem it still occurs
but I will say that a lot of what we've
seen especially relative to it was most
often highlighted in the construction
industry to be clear it happens
elsewhere it happens actually in a lot
of Industries there's misclassification
but what we've seen especially in
construction the last few years is that
they're not telling us they're
independent contractors they're telling
us their employees and then you're
chasing after them and it becomes an
issue where they're just not properly
final question well what uh there has
been a um a great deal of
expansion around the the issue of remote
workers and just uh at first blush it
would seem to me that if that presents
some challenges for the Department to
enforce a variety of laws whether they
be safety and health whether they be
minimum wage whether they be conditions
under which people work uh do you do you
have any sense of of Wibble rap with
that whole thing and do you think this
additional legislation might be needed
to deal with the question of remote
workers and how they interact with those
systems
one issue so we've seen it come up
principally in two areas at least to
date I will say that um in workers comp
a lot of work has been done because
there was I think a misunderstanding
this might seem incredibly
unsophisticated but it's come up enough
that I I'll mention it there's been this
misunderstanding that if people are
injured while working at home that
basically the workers compensation
system is like off limits that it's
entirely it's a shutout because when
you're working at home I so I just we're
trying to make clear to folks no workers
compensation is still at play if someone
was injured while at home they could
still try and assert a claim I would
note that it would be more difficult to
make a claim because and I won't get
well well into it here but when you're
talking about neutral risk and other
factors relative to determination on a
workers comp claim the fact that the
person's working at home might make it
more difficult to assert a claim but
it's certainly not that they're barred
from doing that additionally what we've
seen and this might seem a little in the
weeds but if you look at RSA 275 there's
requirement for reporting pay so
essentially that pay that says that okay
an individual who reports to work
at their employer's request is entitled
to two hours of pay at least for that
day
um that has come up as an issue is what
happens with reporting pay when the
person does not
report anywhere and instead they're
working at home I will say that if the
department if the legislature were to
provide Clarity on that it would be
welcome from the Department the
Department's present position
and people can disagree with this but
the Department's present interpretation
application has been that there's not a
two-hour requirement for reporting pay
the reason being is reporting reporting
to work was looked at as an ambiguous
enough term that we looked to
legislative history and when we look to
legislative history around reporting pay
it was replete with reference to
employees commuting employee spending
gas and how if you had someone driving
someplace and it takes them an hour or
um you should at least pay them for two
hours because of the commuting and again
I I understand people might be
dissatisfied with that application but
that's presently where we've been on
that
um so if there's Clarity around what was
meant by reporting pay and whether
reporting pay should apply to instances
in which folks are uh working from home
that would be welcome by the department
and I've also point out that if someone
disagrees with our interpretation of
reporting pay and appealed that up maybe
we would see
um you know some type of clarity but
again presently that's the Department's
position those are just two examples but
those are the ones that have mostly come
up I think you're right though that
um reporting uh working from home has
brought up certain instant questions
around time worked not as frequently as
the reporting pay issue or the workers
comp issue but some people have asked us
well you know what do I have to pay and
we to be clear if someone's working from
home they're still working and if
they're an hourly employee you still
have to pay them for All Hours worked
Mr Ogden uh the uh boilers for the new
folks here boilers can be any vessel
Under Pressure compressor you know a lot
of businesses so it used to be my
recollection last 15 20 years is that if
you had a vessel under pressure
you folks wanted an inspection done and
insurance carriers would come out there
and they go out and do that and now I I
hear I pleasantly so you folks now
provide that service for fifty dollars
is that the so we yes we do that does
happen I'll still say the vast majority
of inspections are still handled by
insurance company inspectors that they
handle the vast volume of them but we do
have boiler inspectors who do do boiler
inspections
good
I would advise well what you know the
questions you know I have no problem
with the com uh
communication and the conversation going
back and forth
um some of the things that we've
discussed today are not even on our
agenda for bills this year but that's
okay it's good to have that discussion
um I will tell you that some of these uh
rsas that were mentioned 281a I keep
right with me all the time workers
compensation 275 these are our our uh
I'm a Christian so don't get mad at me
this is our Bible
okay uh this is the things that we look
at all the time and one of the things I
would suggest to many of the members is
when you come in front of these the
hearings we have and it states right on
you know this has to do with RSA you
know whatever the RSA 275 and that's
where this the language is that wants to
be amended it's a good idea to just take
a look at that where that is
because sometimes it'll be one word or
one sentence and you don't have the
paragraph before of the other parts of
the law and it makes it just easier to
understand
um when you're when you're trying to
figure out what this bill is and it's
totally foreign to you
um you know what's before and after and
also we have a researcher here
um you can ask questions regarding and
I've already asked one question on one
of the bills how long is the current law
been in place and and what was the
thought process of the law back then
because it's always important to know
what happened 20 years ago why was this
law put into place
um so just some some references
any other questions for the Department
of Labor
I do but I'm going to ask them
all right where's Jeff Cahill
thank you Mr chair and I just wanted to
uh see what the schedule would be for uh
training sessions that you offer to
employers I found those very useful to
attend when we typically do those in the
spring when we have the Slate set up
this year we will send that out if
people are interested attending I know
um last year they did more remote
um because some of the places that we
used to go to for various reasons have
kind of gone away from the big in-person
meetings but once we have us uh again I
would look for it in the spring and when
we have the calendar we will send that
out
all right thank you very much gentlemen
just a couple more things for the
committee
um
these folders have your name on them and
every time you come here for
um
uh or here in your folders will be
papers pertinent to what you're going to
be discussing please leave this behind
so Heather can have it
um and then she'll you know put some
more things in again I don't know what's
going to happen after January 31st she
told me to get all our bills done by
January 31st so we don't have to worry
about it
um
so
um just wanted to reiterate the 19th the
26th we may have to meet on a Tuesday I
know that's not
um what we'd like to do we always like
to meet on Thursdays I can't do any of
the fact that we have nine uh fiscal
note
um bills that have to go out on the by
the 16th of February
um and what I don't want to have to
happen is we're executing them all in
the 16th
because Brian can tell you that doesn't
work out well
um so I will try to give as much
advanced notice I am working with the
clerk and the speaker to find out in
advance when they're going to have
hearings excuse me how sessions so we
can continue to meet meet our schedule
and meet on Thursdays representative
Sullivan
um it's my understanding that not all
fiscal note bills are a second committee
bill so some of those might not be
second committee
um so you might get cut a Break
um I will check into that thank you
um the other thing
um Democrats we're going to have a
caucus
um I'm going to suggest that we take a
quick break for lunch would one o'clock
work for us upstairs at 403
okay so half hour for lunch and then
we'll be upstairs likewise I would like
the Republican members to hang out here
for five minutes or so after we break
any questions of the chair
representative you have any questions
okay
just teasing you buddy
thank you everybody I appreciate your
time
today and thank you for coming let's be